同学们好久不见了
本次代码解读
我们只要关注小引擎的渲染模块
首先会简单介绍一下整个渲染的流程
然后以color grading为例
介绍小引擎中pass的概念
最后我们会为小引擎添加一个简单的暗角pass
本次代码讲解需要同学们对van api有一定的了解
具有编写简单g l i s l shader的能力
同时推荐同学们学习一下render dog
这个工具可以更方便地进行渲染的调试
小引擎的渲染系统叫做render system
在第一次代码讲解中
我们提到render system在global context中的start systems里面初始化
然后在render tick当中
每一帧进行tick
在render system的初始化中
会简单的初始化render
resource中的一些全局贴图
render camera和render scene中的一些光照
并且会初始化render pipeline
在小引擎中
我们将渲染的各个功能抽象为一个一个pass
在pipeline的初始化中
会调用各个pass的初始化过程
在每帧执行的render system tick函数中
首先会调用process web data
这个函数从逻辑层获得要更新的数据
我们可以看一下render swap data这个结构
其中的level resource description
指定新的天空盒和color grading的贴图
game object resource和game object to delete
分别指定要添加和删除的game object
然后camera sweb data更新相机参数
最后三个分别用于创建新的粒子发射器
指定需要tick的粒子发射器
和更新粒子发射器的位置
process sweb data
剩下的代码就是根据这个render swap data
结构体里面描述的需要更新的信息
进行特定的更新
同学们可以自己看一看
其实这里所谓的swap并不是十分准确
因为我们只有渲染
从逻辑拿数据
在进行数据交换之后
我们的渲染系统需要进行每帧实际渲染的
渲染过程
首先是调用一些图形api进行渲染的准备
也就是prepare context函数
然后准备每一帧pass共用的数据
接下来的update visible objects
就是为各个pass筛选各自所需的具体的数据
后面的prepare pass data会调用各个pass的prepare pass data
进行数据准备
最后判断一下使用前向渲染或者延迟渲染
小引擎的渲染
分为形象渲染和延迟渲染两种模式
在forward render函数中会先拿到渲染功能的对象
再执行main camera pass draw forward函数
在main camera pass的draw forward函数中
会执行各个super pass的draw函数
如果是延迟渲染
则执行main camera past draw函数
在延迟渲染中
我们会先执行joe match g buffer函数进行一次绘制
将物体的几何信息存到g buffer中
然后利用g buffer里缓存的数据进行光照计算
我们先来看一下这样一张color grading
look up table
它是一张长为32x32
也就是1024像素
高为32像素的一张贴图
它其实是由32张
32x32的小贴图组成的
我们可以把这32张小贴图组成
如图所示的一个立方体
它就是我们颜色转转换的目标色彩空间
然后我们可以看到一个普通的rgb颜色坐标
它所对应的颜色是如这个三点图所示的
也就是说color grading
它其实际上做的事情
就是把我们原来rgb色彩空间的一个颜色
转换到对应的
有这张贴图表示的色彩空间的颜色
接下来我们要通过编写一个shader
来实现这个事情
首先我们在shader文件夹里面的gsl目录里面
找到color grading.fragment
这个是实现color grading的片段着色器
然后我们先把默认的out color等于color给注释掉
因为我们要从一个三维的空间采样
所以我们至少需要从这张二维贴图上面
采样两次
也就是说
我们首先要在这32张小贴图里面
找出两张贴图
然后采样上面的颜色
最终在mix一下这两个贴图上面对应的颜色
在批改homework 2的作业中
可以看到
有一些同学他是只采样了一次的
那这个结果可能多多少少是有些问题
这个shader实现的细节
其实就是我们先通过color.b乘上color grading
look at the table
它的一个高度
这个高度其实就是这张贴图里面
32张小贴图一个长度
这样子我们将这个b再向上
再分别向上和向下取整
我们就得到了
我们需要需要采样的两张小贴图的index
然后我们再换算一下坐标
在这两张小贴图上
分别根据color.二和color点击进行采样
最终再将这两个采样的结果mix一下
就得到了我们想要的目标颜色
然后我们可以编译运行一下
看一下我们这个shader能不能按照预期
达到我们的color grading的效果
嗯可以看到这个效果其实是有一些问题的
画面中出现了一些奇怪的线条
在这个时候我们就需要打开render dog
进行调试一下
在launch里面选择我们的piccolo editor
然后在render dog里面启动它之后
再按一下f2 就能抓取一帧
然后我们可以在左边的命令列表里面找到
color grading
然后我们可以看一下这一个input和output的结果
在这个时候我已经发现问题所在了
因为我们这个color grading
它其实默认产生了一些meet map
应该就是meet map
导致它的规定
look up table
它最终的精度不够
然后出现了这种线条
我们可以找到mp lame me levels设置的地方
然后将值从默认值零改为一
然后再运行一下
就可以看到能够达到我们预期的效果了
这样我们就实现了一个color grading shader
接下来我们来看一下这个shader到底是怎么样
真正发挥作用的
在皮克罗引擎当中
color grading pass是render pass的一个子类
定义在color grading pass.h和点cpp文件中
它只有三个public的函数
我们先来看一下render pass这个类
其中的global render resource指针
记录了这个pass可能使用到的全局资源
然后descriptor info记录了输入
输出资源在shader中的布局信息
render piplies记录了执行管线的信息
然后visible notes记录了这个pass可见的物体
例如场景中可能有多个游戏对象
然后该pass只会需要用到其中一部分
我们的color grading pass
被设计为main camera pass的一个subpass
这个eom指定了main camera所有的sub pass
sub pass是van api独有的设计
作为van render pass对象的一个部分
一个van的render pass可以包含多个串行的cil pass
前一个super pass的输出
作为后一个super pass的输入
所以我们在这里将color grading
作为main camera pass的一个sub pass
可以看到我们这个sub pass
是在这里被添加到main camera pass里的
我们可以仔细看一下
color grading path的initialize函数
首先他接收一个init info
也就拿到了刚才提到的color grading
look up table这张贴图
然后它会执行以下四步的初始化过程
首先是set up descriptor slayout
就是设置celegrading pass的shader
对应的描述符布局
也就是shader中使用的输入输出资源的排布
这里用到了两个资源
一个是tom mapping pass的输出
一个是调色纹理
然后是set up pipelines函数
color grading pass使用的pipeline是一条graphics pipeline
主体部分为vertex shader和fragment shader
还在此处
还在此处设置一些适口裁剪朝向
剔除混合模式
深度模板等等
必要的信息细节就不展开了
上面设置好的descriptor slayout
也会用于pipeline对象的创建
接下来是set up descript set
有了上面的资源描述符布局信息
还需要设置实际使用到的资源
descriptor set可以理解为资源handle的集合
而update after framebuffer recreate
就是当我们的视口发生变化的时候
进行一些更新操作
他grading pass的draw函数会在main camera
pass的draw里面被调用
周函数就是提交了一些working的命令
好现在让我们来提交一下
我们写好的color grading实现
然后从头开始添加一个新的pass
实现一个暗角的效果
首先我们将这两个color grading pass
点cpp和color grading path.h文件复制一下
然后将它重命名为venient pass
点cpp和vilian pass.h
最后我们将这两个文件里面的color grading
全部都替换成linu
然后我们这个pass也是和color grading pass一样
作为main camera pass的一个supper pass
所以我们需要在main camera
subpass的这些eom里面添加一个bliant some pass
接下来我们仿照一下color grading这个pass
添加我们venient surpass的一些设置和调用
在这里的这些buffer
odd buffer even是seven pass之间的一些缓冲区
所以我们需要对后面的out和你进行一下替换
这里我们需要维护一下
sub pass之间的dependency的关系
首先我们需要添加一个dependency
所以这里要把dependency从八改成九
然后因为我们的venusurpass是添加在celegrading
surpass之后的
所以它的序号是六
然后我们需要把原来的color grading
后面的几个pass重新修改一下
接下来我们编译一下
然后修复一些编译上的错误
呃这个错误就函数我们是实现了的
所以应该是因为我们新添加的文件
没有加入到构建
所以我们需要重新say make一下
ok然后这里提示是找不到venufragment
我们先复制一下color grading fragment
然后将它直接改名为venufragment
我们新建的这个fragment shader
它会在sima构建流程当中转换成一个点h文件
这里将venus从小写改成大写
然后将这个venient resource重新改回
categating resource
我们并没有为minute添加一个贴图
我们的minute暗角效果其实是可以
不需要贴图就实现
好这样修改之后我们就可以运行起来了
但实际上可以看到
现在的效果其实是不符合预期的
因为我们理论上应该是会进行两次color grading
我们现在minute的逻辑是再次进行一个color grading
所以画面应该会变得更明显一点
但是这里还是跟刚才一次color grading一样的效果
我们打开rainy dog
可以看到minute这个pass
它的输入
还是一个没有经过color grading的一个贴图
这个应该是我们sopss之间传递贴图的buffer
没有设置对
我们来重新检查一下
然后将他们的old和even修改一下
好现在编译之后可以看到效果应该是两次
color grading都生效了
因为画面变得更暗了
接下来我们需要真正实现暗角的逻辑
主要是修改vegfragment这个shader
我们实现按脚效果的时候
需要需要一个相比于color grading额外的输入
就是uv
然后我们先随意的设置两个参数吧
还需要修改一下原来的post process vertex trader
我们将它复制一下
然后重命名为linux vertex trader
然后将uv输出一下
然后我们将这里的shader修改成venient
vertex shader
同时由于我们的venient pass它是不需要贴图的
所以我们可以把这个descriptor slayout
给修改一下
好编译运行可以看到边缘有一些发黑
也就是说
我们已经成功地给小引擎添加了一个新的pass
然后实现了一个暗角的效果
通过本次代码解读
可以看到
目前给小引擎添加pass还是比较繁琐的
如果是你
你会怎么设计i hi
让他可以更加方便的修改和添加内容呢
目前小引擎的shader是在simc构建流程中编译的
硬编码进各个pass
你会怎么设计
让小引擎将shader作为一种资产
可以在运行时加载的
欢迎在评论区讨论
或者关注微信公众号games 104
也可以在知乎上邀请games 104回答问题